[Music]
on this Saturday night an indigenous
chief alleges abuse at the hands of RCMP
the minor infraction that led to a
confrontation the alberta man accuses
the Mounties of racism the vociferous
voices in Canada's largest city as
thousands take to the streets and
millions refuse to stay quiet in the
United States as George Floyd is
remembered in his hometown plus Elmo
helps kids understand why people around
the world are angry
global national would Robin Gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us
there are disturbing allegations against
the RCMP tonight a First Nations chief
claims he was the victim of abuse
because he had an expired license plate
chief Allen Adham insists the police
wouldn't have arrested him if he'd been
white he's now calling for a federal
investigation but the Mounties are
standing by their officers David akin
has our top story tonight it was 2 a.m.
on March 10th and our CMP officer
notices that a truck outside this Fort
McMurray casino has an expired license
sticker the RCMP confronts the trucks
owner why are you guys harassing before
my name is Alan Adam I'm the chief of
the Athabasca Chippewa First Nation
within minutes the incident escalates
and chief Adams says an officer struck
him the blood came in my cheek and I
drop to my knees Adam says the officers
were then on top of him he can be heard
on this video identifying himself and
realizes he is injured this video has
not been authenticated by global news as
the individual who took it refuses to be
identified for fear of his own safety
the video about three minutes long was
provided to the media by Adams lawyer
who says it shows Adams arrest chief
Adam was jailed overnight charged with
assaulting police and resisting arrest
this is what he said he looked like when
he was released the next day they always
seem to use accept excessive force and
that has to stop you know enough is
enough
the RCMP have their own video captured
by the dash cam equipment in the RCMP
cruisers the force says their footage
supports its conclusion that the
officers did nothing wrong
Alberta's civilian police watchdog is
not investigating and has not yet been
asked to do so but Federal Public Safety
Minister Bill Blair says the pictures
that he has seen are deeply disturbing
and he says Adams claims are quote
serious and troubling the RCMP will not
release its video or any other
information they say the matter is
before the courts and releasing the
information will jeopardize the case but
Adams lawyer has seen the RCMP video and
he says it backs up Adams claims we want
the police to immediately release the
police car videos let the public judge
this is the truth but the big question
is why how did what appears to be such a
minor infraction turn into such a major
confrontation chief Adams says he knows
why because nobody speaks up for us
chief Adam will get his first day in
court July 2nd
David akin Global News protesters took
to the streets of Canada's largest city
again today we've seen these
demonstrations across North America and
around the world in the aftermath of the
death of George Floyd the 46 year old
black man died in police custody
his last moments were captured on video
showing a police officer pinning him to
the ground with a knee on his neck
Floyd's death has galvanized people to
stand up against racism and call for an
end to police violence against
marginalized communities Sean O'Shay
reports the cries for change for a
second day in Toronto Eddi racism
protesters carried signs and a clear
message
treated unfairly for so long and we're
talking about 400 years plus and enough
is enough
the death of George Floyd in police
custody in Minneapolis last month has
fueled more of this a push for equal
rights fairness and safety when dealing
with police and the fact that it had to
have to be so many lives had to be
killed in order for this stuff to happen
yeah we we need a change and I just
think that the time is now
this March carefully organized and
peaceful those calling for change come
from many walks of life a mother and
father who brought their eight-year-old
for a family there are lessons in all
this so it's very important for us to
convey this kind of a possible
continuity to younger generation so that
they also will take part in this larger
struggle demonstrators knelt and were
asked to reflect silently before making
their walk to the Ontario legislature
others knelt outside the United States
consulate pausing to respect the memory
of George Floyd waiting for 8 minutes
and 46 seconds the amount of time George
Floyd was on the ground before he died
and I support their cause and I support
exactly what they're doing and I think
that the fact that they're showing such
a demonstration for change his death
what many hope will be a lightning rod
for change everything that's fair Sean
O'Shay Global News Toronto a separate
protest has been winding its way through
the streets of Toronto ending in
Ontario's legislature and that's where
we find global Toronto's fahren a surfer
give us a sense of what the crowds were
like and were they peaceful
they were absolutely peaceful a Robin
peaceful but passionate and the other
thing that we saw is quite a bit of
restraint from the part of police they
really gave these protestors space to
send their message out in fact just
moments ago here the small group that's
left a protester is asked the officer is
in front of the Ontario legislature to
take a knee and when they didn't do that
they threw a water bottle at the police
there were no arrests and no one was hit
but this was definitely a peaceful
protest and among the crowd the family
of a man named DeAndre Campbell a 26
year old who was shot and killed by
police in his Brampton home after he
called 911 he was having a mental health
crisis the Ontario Special
Investigations Unit is is investigating
the case but his aunt says you don't
need to look at the states for cases and
issues between police and the black
community this whole family's
traumatized they don't have to live with
this they don't have to look at this is
this is famine look at their faces
they travelled as a generation of the
family for the rest of their lives were
traumatized far who are the organizers
of this particular protest and how is it
different from the others the organizers
say that they are volunteers their
students and various community members
they say they are not affiliated with
black lives matter in fact black lives
matter put out a tweet saying that it is
not it is not organising any of the
protests happening this weekend but
organizers do tell me that they have
been helping behind the scenes we saw
about five six different protests
happening at one time here in the City
of Toronto and as you can see things
have now winded down Robin Farah Nasser
in Toronto
protesters aren't staying quiet in the
US tonight it is now day 12 of
demonstrations south of the border the
largest one is in Washington tens of
thousands of people gathered in the
newly renamed black lives matter Plaza
before marching through the city they're
relentless with their demands for change
as Jennifer Johnson explains some US
cities are now making drastic police
reforms
protesters outside the White House
taking a knee for eight minutes 46
seconds the length of time George Floyd
was pinned to the ground tens of
thousands in the nation's capital
demanding an end to police brutality
black lives really do matter it's not
just a slogan or movement it's the
reality of life similar protests across
the country as millions of Americans
refused to stay quiet almost two weeks
after Floyd died police in several
cities have used tear gas rubber bullets
and in many scenes violence but the
protests keep coming I'm very scared but
I also hope that I don't like one day I
won't have to fear for my brother's life
or if I have a son I want to fear for
his life former officer Derek Chapman
has been charged with murder three other
former arresting officers have been
charged with aiding and abetting
Minneapolis City Council has now
announced changes to try and prevent
another death banning chokeholds like
the one used on Floyd and requiring
officers to intervene any time they see
unauthorized use of force over 30 states
and pass different measures to address
problems in the area of policing much
more clearly needs to be done local
jurisdictions are cracking down on
officers using force against protesters
- and Buffalo have been charged with
second-degree assault after knocking
down the 75 year old man supporters
cheered for the officers as they left
court Saturday morning after their
suspensions all 57 members of the police
department's emergency response team
resigned the district attorney stands by
his decision this is the last thing that
I want to do prosecute a teammate we're
on the same team here in Tacoma
Washington the mayor is calling on four
officers to be fired and prosecuted over
the death of 33 year old Manuel Ellis
three months ago
a video has emerged appearing to show
Ellis being restrained on the ground
Ellis is overheard on a police radio
recording saying the words Floyd also
said I can't breathe on Wednesday the
medical examiner ruled his death a
homicide
we want to see justice
my son and we should have had to wait
three months meanwhile in North Carolina
George Floyd's body arrived for another
memorial service
despite the somber occasion onlookers
cheered a show of support for a man who
has become the nation's symbol of police
brutality and calls for change Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington
the NFL is now attempting to make amends
for not listening to black players who
called on the league to condemn racism
in 2017 President Donald Trump railed
against players for taking a knee during
the national anthem the league's owners
then required players to stand
Commissioner Roger Goodell is now
apologizing
we the National Football League admit we
were wrong for not listening to NFL
players earlier and encourage all to
speak out and peacefully protest without
black players there would be no National
Football League and the protests around
the country are emblematic of the
centuries of silence inequality and
oppression of black players coaches fans
and staff in 2016 Colin Kaepernick been
a quarterback for the San Francisco
49ers began taking a knee during the
u.s. national anthem to protest police
violence against the black community
other players followed suit but
Kaepernick's football career essentially
ended because of his protest he became
an unrestricted free agent in 2017 and
hasn't received another opportunity in
the NFL despite saying he wants to play
Goodell did not mention Kaepernick's
name in his apology around the world
people are energized by what is
happening in the United States
[Music]
thousands gathered in the heart of
London holding up black lives matter
signs the British government had warned
people to stay away because of the
pandemic the UK is still under a partial
lockdown and mass gatherings are banned
a lot of protesters were wearing masks
but there was little to no social
distancing in Germany anti racism
rallies were held in several major
cities in Hamburg thousands held up
signs and chanted all while taking a
knee in Berlin protesters took a moment
of silence to voice their outrage over
Floyd's death in Australia an estimated
30,000 people marched peacefully through
Sydney the rally was initially deemed
unlawful under Cova 19 restrictions but
it was legalized by a last-minute court
appeal the protest was inspired by
Floyd's death but the demonstrators are
also calling for an end to police
mistreatment of Indigenous Australians
coming up thousands are without power in
New Brunswick
after a wicked storm whips up strong
winds
a sudden thunderstorm in Fredericton
brought severe rain and strong winds
that snapped trees and downed power
lines that caused a fire at a downtown
apartment leaving at least six people
homeless several mobile homes were also
severely damaged but no one was injured
up to 13,000 people were left without
power after the storm blew through a
storm of condemnation continues to swirl
around u.s. President Donald Trump and
his handling of racial tensions in that
country there are calls for Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau to take a
tougher stance with his American ally
this weekend on the West block Mercedes
Stevenson looks at that issue Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau hasn't said much
that's been directly critical of
President Donald Trump's words and
actions when it has come to the
anti-racism protests in the United
States but he has engaged in some
symbolic actions from his pregnant pause
heard round the world when he was asked
his thoughts on president Trump's words
- taking a knee on Parliament Hill in
the midst of thousands of protesters who
gathered there on Friday but there are
some Canadians including protesters who
chanted at the prime minister on Friday
who would like mr. Trudeau to be more
blunt in his criticism of the American
president among those Canadians is NDP
leader jug meat sing mr. Trump's
comments are are irresponsible and
reprehensible that it is wrong to incite
anger and incite hatred that what a
president should be doing is finding
ways to bring people together and that
is not what President Trump did and not
only does the Prime Minister of Canada
Prime Minister Trudeau but all global
leaders have a responsibility to call
out when something is happening that is
so dangerous to people after mr. Singh
called for mr. Trudeau to directly
address the president and his comments
we put the question to minister of
diversity inclusion and youth bar -
anger of what she thinks the Prime
Minister should do and whether he should
say something more specific when it
comes to Donald Trump this is what she
had to say I will say that you know
leadership is essential but when it
comes to racism in Canada it
this we need to get our own house in
order and it's not good enough just to
be better than other countries
we believe in our values include having
an inclusive Canada and if we want to
truly inclusive Canada then we need to
deep do a deep dive within our own
institutions and make the necessary
changes to have better outcomes and
what's clear with what we're seeing take
place in Canada is that we have a lot of
work to do what Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau's government has been clear in
their calls for an end to inequality and
racism in Canada we'll have more
tomorrow on the specific policy
proposals that activists and the
opposition are calling on the government
to implement to address those issues
right here at home thanks for sadie's
and you can see more tomorrow on the
West block the federal government has
struck a deal with Bombardier to
manufacture jets for the Canadian Armed
Forces executive fleet bombard a will
produce two Challenger 650 jets for the
Department of National Defense the jets
are used to transport the prime minister
Governor General and cabinet ministers
yesterday the company announced its
slashing 2,500 jobs in its aviation
division citing a drop in demand for
private jets OPEC and its allies have
agreed to keep cutting oil production
until the end of next month supply will
continue to be cut by nine point seven
million barrels a day the move is aimed
at boosting energy prices that collapsed
during the pandemic the deal has helped
crude prices double in the last two
months after almost 10 percent of the
world's supply was withdrawn benchmark
Brent crude climbed to a three-month
high on Friday above $42 US a barrel
still ahead how communities in the UK
are coming together to honor those lost
to the pandemic
you are watching global national a small
ceremony was broadcast online today to
mark the 76th anniversary of the d-day
landing on Juno Beach because of the
pandemic the families of the 14,000
Canadian troops who landed there were
unable to attend but a handful of
Canadian and French officials paid
tribute to those who gave the ultimate
sacrifice Juno was one of five beaches
key to the Allies invasion of
german-occupied France during the Second
World War and one of the most important
battles in Canadian military history
it's hard to fathom the loss of life
that Britain is facing due to the
pandemic over 40,000 deaths linked to
Cova 19 have been confirmed in the UK
that's five times the number in Canada
with no funerals or wakes being held
traditional grieving isn't possible but
as London eases its lockdown some
creativity is helping a community mourn
Christel commencing explains it's not
fancy just some plywood and paint but
the big block letters are giving people
this space to grieve and remember today
it was celebrating my loss it's
celebrating the life that my brother had
the love that he left behind and today
we could share that the virus that
causes kovat 19:00 is still circulating
in london and lives are still being lost
while the lockdown is being eased people
are searching for ways to come together
while keeping their distance I felt the
need to commemorate the the death of my
friend rabbi Pinter and and so we
rearranged the hoarding and turned it
from saying the words thank you to
saying the words we grieve and began
putting up the names of those who have
died so once a week Reverend Taylor
heads to the nearby park to be with
Stanford Hill community members and
listen we lost him
about four weeks ago
and obviously like all of us we can't
learn properly so st. Paul's Cathedral
in London is also trying to help honour
lives lost during the pandemic while
creating a document of these difficult
times the remember me web site only
launched last month but there are pages
and pages of loving tributes the project
was promoted by the Prince of Wales he
also had the virus I feel particularly
for those for instance who lost their
loved ones but we're unable to to be
with them at the time that's to me the
most ghastly thing there is no good time
to lose a loved one but projects like
these are becoming increasingly
important as traditional mourning just
isn't possible crystal Romancing Global
News London
up next our it's for racism
ssp streets residents explain why the
world is taking a stand you're never too
young to learn about racism and how to
stand up to it that's the message of a
special townhall put on by CNN and
Sesame Street
my friend has an important question how
do you use fine to classmate questions
why is black lives matter necessary kids
and parents asked Elmo and friends
answered from explaining what led to the
protests and what white privilege means
no stone went unturned the hour ended
with some powerful reminders I can do
better I can do better I can do better
we will and that is global national for
this Saturday I'm Robin Gill tonight
your Canada is camel ttan New Brunswick
thank you for watching good night
[Music]